ibm created cloud packs to help
businesses
more easily move from where you are to
where you'd like to be
but what are ibm cloud packs cloud packs
are pre-integrated ai-powered software
designed to run in any cloud environment
managed by a single intelligent control
plane
to help you modernize your applications
to put it plainly
cloud packs are essentially
containerized software
that can run anywhere now let's talk
about what that can do for your business
ibm believes that a cloud strategy is
key to digital transformation
and that ai can accelerate innovation
and
drive transformation ibm cloud packs are
our
answer as to how you can gain agility
and flexibility
and accelerate innovation with ai and
automation
here's how it works ibm cloud packs
brings you the best of ibm software
capabilities
to help you modernize with ease predict
outcomes automate at scale
and secure everything because they're
pre-integrated
and pre-certified to create one cohesive
plug-and-play platform
you don't need an army of developers and
data scientists
to deploy an entire portfolio of
capabilities you can easily
use the team you have and innovate with
confidence
backed by ibm's deep industry and
technical expertise
this radically simplifies and
accelerates development
to get faster time to value the best
part
because ibm cloud packs are built on red
hat
openshift you can modernize with ease
across any cloud based on container and
kubernetes technology
you can run applications anywhere on
premises
on all clouds and on the edge and with
one platform throughout you can
integrate security across the breadth of
your idea state so it's secure
from the ground up also with ibm cloud
packs
you can manage the complexity of
connecting moving and managing
applications
and workloads across fragmented
environments
all from a single intelligent control
plane it removes silos and empowers
growth
and innovation across your enterprise
ultimately
accelerating your digital transformation
now that you have a pretty good idea of
what cloud packs are
we invite you to continue exploring our
website or consult with an ibm expert
for a solution that's right for you
you